[APPLAUSE]
And here are the nominees for
Best Animated Feature Film.
Before we went in,
we looked each other
and said we had a great
run on this movie.
We should just be proud and
happy no matter what happens.
Are you ready?
Frozen.
[APPLAUSE]
I don't think I remember
much of anything
after they said our name.
We knew that Walt had been
given a special Academy Award
but Disney Animation
hadn't won one yet.
It meant so much.
My heart was racing.
We're going to do this together,
because we're collaborative.
But we'll be fast.
And we all wanted
to say something,
even though the Academy said
only one person can talk.
Every step of the way
we did it together.
So we just feel like we
had to do it that way.
We're bringing this home to you.
And for our personal
families, and dearest friends,
thank you so much.
You guys are very sweet.
My son had passed away just
before the movie came out.
You guys said you
want to say something?
I said yeah, I think I would.
We'd like to dedicate this
to our guardian angel.
That's my son, Ryder Buck.
A lot of people
afterwards and the press
like who is this Ryder Buck?
Who is this guardian angel?
You're out.
You can't go back in
until the commercial.
And I was there with Cate
Blanchett, Julia Roberts,
and Glenn Close.
And they just looked.
And they were just
like congratulations.
My sister was with
me, so she was like--
I was like--